breaking news breaking news coming in
hot from orlando from our own taylor
rooks
the joint call with the owners just
concluded sources say
players had a list of important things
players want organizational changes
including dedicated coalitions with
full-time jobs
to manage the issues voting police
reform etc
wanting to be proactive instead of
reactive more news coming from taylor
rooks sources say
michael jordan has taken a strong
position to help owners
see different point of views on today's
call he said
he isn't just speaking as an owner or
even a player he's
speaking as a black man in another tweet
sources say lebron james
was the last player to speak on the call
he delivered a strong
thoughtful message to the owners his
main point was that the work has to
continue
and the owners have to truly dedicate to
advocating
this cause who fans was good you are now
rocking with the best role parish here
in studio b
breaking news right here and usually we
like to entertain and enlighten but
today we'll focus on enlightening with
everything that's been going on in the
past 24 hours
and with that being said i welcome in
hall of famer gary payton good to see
you
number one gp everything that's happened
over the last couple of days we're going
to get a quick thought for you but in
the meantime in a second
we want to bring in our own taylor rooks
who's been
doing an outstanding job in orlando
covering everything
you were the first person to report all
this news
especially the list that's been
submitted by the players let's start
there
that list that was submitted to league
execs and coaches tell us a little bit
more about that information
yeah for sure so before the joint call
with the owners
players gathered together and figured
out okay what exactly do we want to say
to them what exactly do we want from
them they
put together a list of things that they
thought would be best to affect
some type of change for police brutality
racial injustice but one of the main
points on that list was a focus
on kind of grassroots programs being
able to bring in those that have been on
the ground fighting for these causes in
their cities
for quite some time and that was the
main thing they think that the mba
should have a dedicated coalition
people whose full-time job is to tackle
these
issues like voter suppression voting in
general
police reform education and that was
probably their main point to owners this
is something we can do that is tangible
change
and actionable item and that was the
main focus of the call today is creating
that coalition
whose job is to tackle these issues the
next question obviously i want to talk
about michael jordan he's obviously the
chairman
of the charlotte hornets he is also the
chairman of the labor union however
you said had he really stepped in on
your tweet and really
stepped in i don't want to say as a
mediator but just
shed some more light on mj's role
working between the owners and the
players bringing them closer together
yes i have been told by multiple people
that michael jordan has stepped up in
such a big way i said in the tweet for
him to be on the call
with these owners and really trying to
make sure that they see things from
different points of view
and him saying i am on this call not as
an
owner not as a former player but simply
as a black man
and that has been one of the themes that
has resonated throughout the bubble
here in orlando and you know it's not
just michael jordan i
have been told that doc rivers is
somebody that players have just
have always respected but have such a
newfound respect
for how vocal he has been throughout
this movement i asked him what
he has learned about coaching during
this time he said you know what taylor i
have always been political
but i haven't been political enough and
so what he's trying to do now
is make sure he is political enough for
a time that is calling for him to be
when you're talking about other former
players dwayne wade is somebody who has
been very active
in these calls talking to players he's
talking to them very
often and they are really trying to get
inside and outside voices on how they
can
advance this movement as much as
possible
all this being said with michael jordan
going to the older the older guys the
older owners in this nba
with him being the superstar that he is
do we think that we're going to get
these older owners to understand what
they need to be
they need to be done on their teams in
their in
in our cities to get this done
well you know that was one of my
questions right which is like okay
what's next
how optimistic are we that some of these
you know demands for lack of better word
on this list are met and everybody said
they were optimistic they felt that the
call was
productive which i think is the most
that you can ask for people listening to
you
people hearing you and people
understanding and there's this
overwhelming
feeling here that the owners are getting
it more than maybe people thought
before the bubble but it helps that
there are stars really backing it like i
said in those tweets lebron james was
the final voice on that call which was
really important because
that's what he stressed was that this
only works if we're all in this together
this only works if we care about this
genuinely at a human level when we're
not playing basketball
this only works if we believe in it and
players are starting to feel like owners
are seeing that more than they did
before
taylor obviously you spoke on sorry gp
just
just to add this the overall mood
obviously there's been a
a vast range of emotions over the last
24 to 48 hours
what's the overall mood from everybody
being from players owners
team personnel league execs down there
in orlando
honestly i think players are exhausted
and i think that it is a very layered
extra
exhaustion you know i think they're
exhausted they are in the middle of this
movement and they are being asked to be
the faces of something that
in a lot of ways that burden doesn't
belong on them
the burden does not always lie on the
oppressed
it lies on the oppressor and i think
players are in some ways
exhausted that they're constantly having
to talk about this but they know it's
their responsibility and it's something
that means a lot to them
i think they're also exhausted because
of the state america is in
right now i think that it's exhaustion
for sure but i also think that there is
a lot of hope and more than anything
there is a lot of action i i'll pull
this up i asked a player you know
what's been your biggest takeaway from
some of these calls so far
how are you feeling and he said my
biggest takeaway is that we're not doing
enough and we have work to do
this was a wake-up call to the whole
league to really check guys
and say that kneeling isn't enough
post-game messages
aren't enough and that we have to really
get involved in our respected cities
our home cities and be active we also
have to help each other
because we can't do it alone so while
they are exhausted and they're tired and
in all honesty i think some of them are
really sad about the state of things
they also feel very motivated to do what
they can
to change the world in whatever way
possible
dear taylor with but that's being said i
was going to ask that question
but now that they are exhausted in their
minds how do we think that this
basketball is going to come back and how
are we going to think about this show
that they got to give they still got
basketball games
to do how do you think that exhaustion
will take over onto the basketball court
so that they can give a good a good show
for the fans and the television
yeah i mean i think that at the end of
the day basketball is basketball right
these are the
best basketball players in the world
when they step onto the court you're
going to see
competition at the highest level you're
gonna see great games and
for some of them i think that that
really is secondary now i think that
we're still gonna see people giving up
their platforms and interviews
two causes whether it's jacob blake
brianna taylor just police brutality in
general
hbcus you saw chris paul deliver that
great interview with stephanie reddy
these are all things that are important
we've seen lebron give up his press
conference to talk about
brianna taylor and so many other
injustices so
i think the more that we get that the
more we'll feel like yes the basketball
is important but we're just adding
another element that touches humans
taylor we can't thank you enough
outstanding work as always
thank you again and we'll talk to you
again as we work our way closer back to
basketball
nice to talk to you both stay healthy
miss y'all
much love that you tell us taylor rooks
right there from turner sports with us
and bleach reports